foreign
[Music]
the number one source of carbon
emissions in the United States is coming
from Transportation globally it's number
two and the majority of that comes from
our personal use our cars and trucks how
do we consume less energy while meeting
the needs that people have of
Transportation
[Music]
the majority of car trips in the world
today are less than five miles it's a
simple question can we get more people
to drive less and bike more and scooter
more to where they go the average trip
on an e-bike or e-scooter produces less
than seven percent carbon Emissions on
equivalent car trip micro Mobility is
dramatically more green than
Alternatives and we're working every
single day to reduce our own carbon
emissions even further so what sometimes
happens is that a company would say what
is the dirtiest part of our business
let's just Outsource it and if we
Outsource it we've solved our problems
but that doesn't actually solve your
problem because somebody else is
polluting and emitting if we're going to
live up to our own ideals then we need
to do the core of what folks have always
done Reduce Reuse and recycle the early
days of microability we took a consumer
scooter or a consumer ebike and we put
it into a commercial space and what that
meant was that our average scooter
lasted a month imagine that every month
we need to buy an entire fleet for the
world and that was not green and it
created enormous amount of shipping
costs manufacturing costs upstream and
then ultimately it created problems in
terms of end of life of our scooters and
e-bikes and so we found manufacturing
partners that can build scooters and
e-bikes that last four years five years
rather than a month we also then said
okay it's not just how long it lasts it
also depends on how many of the parts we
can reuse and so we started to say let's
redesign our entire e-bikes and
e-scooters so that if a scooter does
break we can take it apart and reuse
many parts of that scooter we started to
use a swappable Battery Technology not
only does it increase the life it also
reduce the number of trips we have to
take back and forth to actually support
our Fleet and we're constantly working
to reduce the amount of waste that we
actually sent to landfill once our
batteries get to the end of life they
may not have sufficient charge to power
an e-bike but that battery can still
power many many things we started
partnering with a portable speaker maker
and we take that battery that today
doesn't have enough juice to power
somebody on a scooter and we turn it
into the battery for the portable
speaker and it extends and it recycles
into that life a lot of these things
wouldn't be part of our direct carbon
emissions but we care about it because
the thing that we have to count is the
true end-to-end life cycle of our
products when I look across all these
things it's not one thing it's not two
things it's a hundred little actions we
do and it starts with understanding and
measuring our own environmental impact
and challenging ourselves to do better
we have to work at building a future of
transportation that is shared affordable
but most importantly carbon free
thank you